Psychoanalytic thought today.
Depth psychology.
That's a better way to think about
psychoanalysis.
Freud.
Freud is not the only contributor to the
Corpus of psychoanalytic ideas.
Adler who we won't talk much about
was certainly that there was smart and
he's a,
he's under,
he's underrated.
Today,
wasn't as charismatic as Freud and you
know,
so,
and he didn't have the same flare for
writing I suppose.
But he,
his ideas foreshadow the development of
leaders,
cybernetic ideas,
which we'll talk about by a good margin.
So add,
they're really had some,
some smart things to say.
Um,
Yoni is the first one we're going to
talk about day and next time I'm going
to talk about him in some ways
indirectly because the best way to
understand healing is to show you what
you do with his ideas rather than really
presenting the ideas themselves.
But I can give you a bit of an overview.
So
one of the things that differentiates
the depths psychologists from say
behavior therapists and even from
cognitive scientists,
is that you might say in one way they're
more mystical,
which means more from the romantic
tradition.
Then the cognitive scientists in the
behaviorists.
So there's a temperamental split their
aid,
because people who are high in openness
and both Freud and young were very,
very high in trade.
Openness are very interested in the
domain of the imagination and the domain
of fantasy because they have very active
imaginations and they have very active
fantasy lights and they're good
visualizers.
And so,
um,
one of the things I've noticed in my
clinical practice,
there's always been a joke about depth
psychologists that if you go see a
Friday and you have Freud and dreams,
and if you go see a union,
you have union dreams.
And I suppose that means if you go to a
behavioral therapist that you don't have
any dreams at all.
But I actually think there's some truth
in that because the more pragmatic
people that more practical people are
not going to be attractive to therapists
who deal with issues that have to do say
with the imagination and fantasy.
And so there's a natural parsing.
And one of the things I've noticed in my
clinical practice is that
imagine that that people,
so those would be open and creative
people,
um,
have a dream life.
That big cries out to be interpreted in
architectural terms.
Like I've had clients number of them
now,
I have one right now.
I mean it's,
it's his dream life is,
is it's so remote.
It's so rich.
It's remarkable.
And he's,
if he's a genius dreamer,
every time he comes in and it's like he
has two dreams or three dreams,
they're coherent,
they're complex sleep plotted,
they're interesting and,
and they chart what's going on in his
life and they tell him what he should
do.
It's like it's,
it's great.
It's,
but everyone is like that.
I also have clients who never dreamed at
all.
And then I've also seen when I've
lectured to people,
I see this most particularly in medical
students cause I've lectured a bit to
medical students is like,
so maybe I'll do a seminar for the,
for the medical students and tell them a
little bit about the symbols of
transformation really because they're
involved in,
first of all transforming because their
medical students and so you have to
transform it into a doctor.
And also of course they're helping
people through transformations all the
time,
often negative but not always soft,
sometimes positive because sometimes you
get better.
And so it's useful possibly for them to
understand those processes or deeply.
Generally with the medical school
students I do half lecture that's more
on like trade psychology,
the more behavioral and half of it on
the more symbolic stuff,
which is kind of like this class is.
Um,
and there's always about half the
medical students on whom the more
symbolic stuff just falls flat.
It just,
they just don't,
it's like talking about color that
people who are coming are blind.
And I,
I've,
I've thought about this a lot and I
really do think it's face to
temperamental differences.
So you don't,
if you have an active fantasy life and
you have Mac and imagination and you're
a good visualizer and you dream a lot,
then that's the sort of person you are.
And if you,
and if you're on the other end of the
scale,
which would be that you're very
conscientious,
let's say,
and very low in openness,
which also tends to make you more
conservative in your political
presuppositions.
By the way,
then dream analysis is probably not for
you,
partly because you're just not going to
come up with that many dreams.
And even if they,
even if you do,
they won't necessarily be informative.
So you know,
there's been a very long battle in some
ways in the psychological and
psychiatric community between people who
take different perspectives on how you
might address psychological problems.
But I don't know if the,
the issue of tight has been thought
about seriously enough in that regard
because we're really only just starting
to understand the dimensions,
the actual dimensions of personality
property,
and to figure out what it means to be on
one end of say,
openness and versus the other way.
Especially if you're intelligent,
you can be intelligent,
not open.
Those are complicated people.
They got very analytical minds to make
good lawyers.
Like lawyers are often,
and this is something you might think
about if you're planning to become a
lawyer.
Um,
if you're high in openness,
it's a bad job for you.
You will not be happy.
You need to be really conscientious,
like off the scale.
And it helps to be disagreeable to so
because if you're too agreeable,
well you're supposed to weigh in if
you're a lawyer.
And I supposed to like nicely let the
other person,
when you know you're supposed to fight
to win.
And so you have to be kind of fighting
to do that.
And if you're high in agreeableness than
it's a job that's kind of grates against
your temperament.
So anyways,
so young
you work you,
and I think the best way to think about
yoga is that he was a student of two
people.
He was a student of Friedrich Nietzsche
and who was a student of Freud.
And although the Friday ends,
when they write the history of
psychoanalytic thought,
they pretty much portray young is up as
like a derivative thinker of Freud.
Um,
it's not the right way to think about is
positioning historically because in some
ways what,
what young was trying to do was to
answer the question that needs opposed
at the end of the 19th century because,
and the reason that no one was trying to
answer it was because he believed it was
the most important question that had
been posed at the end of the 19th
century.
And that was,
you know,
there's a famous quote by nature,
right?
Done.
I'm sure you've all heard it and that's
the boat that God is dead.
So,
but needs just said essentially was God
is dead and we have killed him.
That's a different idea and we'll never
find enough water to wash away the
blood.
And so it wasn't like a triumphal state,
but on each as part,
even though when you hear it quoted,
you always hear it quoted that way.
It's like it's a sort of victory
daughter,
her dad,
you know,
or something to celebrate.
It's not what nature thought at all.
In fact,
he thought all hell was going to break
loose because of it.
And he predicted as much like in the,
in the,
in the 1870 [inaudible].
I mean he predicted what was going to
happen in the 20th century with re it's
ridiculous accuracy,
like uncanny.
And that's part of it because you know,
nature was one of these people like
young who are very grounded in their
deep,
deep imaginations and so they get wind
of the currents that are moving through
society long before normal people do.
So in some sense,
you know,
you can imagine that in any given
population,
even within you guys,
there's some of you guys who were living
in like 50 years ago and there's some of
you living now and there's somebody that
you live in 50 years in the future.
It depends on how intelligent,
imaginative versus how conservative you
are.
Cause it's not like everyone develops at
exactly the same historical rate.
And you get people like Nicha for
example,
or dusty Yefsky,
they're like a hundred years ahead of
everyone else.
And so you know,
people don't even know what to do with
them.
But stendhal was like that too though.
The writer,
he wrote the 1830s and he was convinced
that he was a hundred years ahead of his
time.
And stylistically that was probably
about right.
So,
and the people who are profits regarded
as profits in isn't say old testament
tradition.
They were the same sort of people.
It's like they had their ear to the
ground in a sense and they could tell
what was going on underneath everybody's
facade.
It echoed in them.
And often as the stories go,
and I'm sure they have,
they have a mythological accuracy to
them.
The people who are picking up the
underground currency indicating often
catastrophe felt absolutely compelled
even at the risk of their own skin to
warn people.
So,
so navy,
so young was definitely one of these
people.
And now this question,
God is dead and we have killed him.
Led me to pose another question,
which was,
well,
what are we going to do to replace him?
Because need to believe.
And I think it,
I think he was absolutely right about
this.
I can't see how it could be otherwise.
He believed that the morality that it's
structured,
Western society was predicated on the
fundamental axiom of divinity.
And so like the,
as far as nature was concerned,
the whole Corpus of morality was
dependent on there on that,
that axiom being true or at least being
accepted as true.
And when that accident was knocked out
by saying that conflict between science
and religion,
because in some sense that's what did
it.
Then the whole system no longer had
anything to stand on and could become
entirely questionable.
And so Nicha pointed that out.
And then Dostoyevsky who was writing
basically at the same time said,
well,
if there's no god than anything is
permitted.
And what he meant by that was really,
in some sense,
what he meant by that was morality turns
into what what you can get away with
because there's nothing final about it.
There's nothing transcendent about it.
And like we've played these problem own
intellectually.
You guys are still right in the middle
of this battle,
whether you know it or not.
I mean,
so what happened in the 20th century was
that one of the consequences of that
loss of an UN fundamental underpinning
led Europe to swing radically to
political extremes.
You know,
the Nazis were to think of that,
to think of the Nazis without thinking
of that as it religious transformation
is that's just not right.
It was religious transformation and it
wasn't a good one.
So like it was a regression in some
sense too,
to a morality that was way pre
Christian.
Like you said,
it wasn't not good.
And then you know,
you had the same,
it was like the rise of the state as an
alternative to God.
Well we s we saw what that produced.
It produced hundreds of millions of
painful deaths and it just about
destroyed the world.
So it was a,
it was a bad problem.
And you know,
when we sort of skirted our way through
that miraculously,
you know,
that all,
I don't really think World War II came
to an end until 1980 1989 you know,
because there was the whole cold war
period after,
after the Germans and the Japanese had
surrendered.
But I mean we just went from one war to
another.
We just went to another one that
everyone was too afraid to fight.
It was still a war,
you know?
And that didn't end until 1989 first by
some miracle,
God only knows why,
you know,
it never degenerated into a
thermonuclear exchange and then it was
close,
man,
we just barely squeaked through that.
There is,
there were two times during that period,
one in 1964 during the Cuban missile
crisis where they had those buddy icbm
is primed.
And so the way they work with in the
control panel,
which kind of looked like a star trek,
you know the old star Trek sets,
there'd be like a panel here and there
was a little place you can put a key and
about 20 feet over there and there'd be
another guy with a key.
And if he turned his key and held it for
10 seconds at the same time,
he turned his key and held it for 10
seconds.
Then the missile launched and an
intercontinental ballistic missile is a
bullet and I mean that technically it's
not a guided missile.
Once you launch it like you,
you shoot a bullet,
it's gone and you don't get to tell the
bullet to come back.
Once it's gone,
you can turn around like a cruise
missile,
an intercontinental ballistic missile.
It goes where you aimed it and you don't
get to bring it back.
And so during the Cuban missile crisis,
the keys were in the locks.
So we were 10 seconds away,
man,
I tell you that,
that was a tight keyhole.
We've barely squeaked through that wall
and looks like by about 1989 then that
collective consciousness or human would
say the collective unconscious of the
human race had decided that,
well maybe having it all end in like
apocalyptic annihilation and wasn't
necessarily for the best.
It's interesting because writers like
girth f he wrote Faust and faust as this
tale of a man who makes a bet with the
devil so that he can acquire infinite
knowledge essentially.
And the devil in faust is named
Mephistopheles and dirt that was trying
to explain what human evil,
evil per se,
what it's motive was.
And he did a lovely job.
It's so smart what he said and he said,
the devil is basic hypothesis and of
course spirit,
the expresses this and poetry is that
life is so unbearably cruel and random
and tragic that it would be better if it
had never existed at all.
And you know,
you believe me,
there'll be times in your life where you
think that you know where something has
just knocked you off your feet
completely on,
on just manner,
you know,
and that thought it will rise up.
And like it's a compelling thought.
And I think that's the thought that he
would means we're wrestling with,
well we've been wrestling with it
forever,
but we didn't really vote on it until
1989 you know,
and life barely one.
And you know,
life isn't troublesome businesses.
It's a tragedy.
And you know,
everyone asks himself now and then is if
their consciousness is worth the pain
while the answer that is,
it depends on how you live.
That is the answer to that.
But you know,
that's a complicated answer.
And just because you know that answer,
it doesn't mean that you know how to
live anyways.
What's happened since 1989 as far as I'm
concerned,
is that intellectuals who were often
possessed by the worst sorts of demons
because they actually think that their
intelligence can guide the property in,
in,
in like the complex moral landscape.
It's not the case.
You see most intellectuals,
and this is certainly a case of most
intellectuals in the universities in
the,
especially in the late 20th century,
they were committed marxists like way
past wouldn't intuitively,
you know,
George Orwell,
by 1955 he was a left winger,
brilliant guy.
He'd already figured out that whatever
was going on in the Soviet Union was not
good.
So,
you know,
like if you had your eyes open,
you were done with that by you know,
10 years after World War II.
But people like Sean Paul Sartre were
members of the Communist Party way
longer than they had any ethical right
whatsoever to be.
You know,
it's,
was it absolutely murderous philosophy
and,
but,
but intellectuals toyed with that,
they still toy with it.
And the universities,
you know,
except it's turned into postmodernism,
which has Marxism under a new guys,
you know,
and a lot of the postmodern thought is
not only left wing disguised,
but it's also nihilistic.
And that's actually the other problem
that the death of God produces.
One is,
okay,
I,
I don't have a religious foundation.
I don't have any foundation under my
feet to buttress my moral claims or even
to sort of help me determine what life
is worth in the face of tragedy.
So I need something to replace that.
And then Poof,
that's the state,
which is a really bad replacement cause
if you think God's bad,
like you just try stellan on for try it
on for size for a while.
And Mao as well,
you know,
and Hitler as well.
It's not like this was a phenomena that
was only linked to one say culture of
people.
Everybody became susceptible to it.
And the same murderous thing happened
every time people try that.
So it was China,
Cambodia,
Vietnam,
like wherever the communists got into
power man pit people died by the
hundreds of thousands.
So Paul Paul,
the guy who emptied the Cambodian cities
had killed 7 million.
Sorry,
I think it was 3 million people.
He got his,
he got his graduate degree at the
Sorbonne in France and he said what he
was going to do when he went back to
Cambodia.
You know,
he didn't outline the whole
murderousness element,
but he certainly had all the theory laid
down in his fine French academy.
So,
you know,
we missed with ideas in the universities
and if we don't do it properly,
like people die.
It's important to get your ideas right.
So one answer to the death of God is
worshiped,
worship the state,
the other is doership nothing.
It's,
it's nihilism.
There's no distinction between anything
and everything is pointless.
And there,
there's a massive strain of that sort of
underground theorizing in postmodernism
and a psychoanalyst,
especially a union,
would look at the postmodern response,
which is nihilistic and the fascist
response,
which is sort of recourse to the state
as motivated by something even deeper
than that.
And that's the sort of process that
Nisha was describing now for young is he
wrote a book called Ion,
for example.
And if you want to have nightmares for
the rest of your life,
that's a really good book to read.
I mean it's,
it's that book just terrified me because
young,
what he did in that book basically was
investigate the fantasy that he believed
that all of Western civilization had
been predicated on for the last 4,000
years now because you really believed
that what drove human beings,
and it's a Piagetian perspective,
it's some weird ways was the revelation
of the success of unconscious revelation
of fantasies were at the forefront of
our movement into unknown territory.
So it's like there's unknown territory
and then there is known territory,
but there's this weird intermediaries
space between them and that intermediary
space where you kind of know but kind of
don't know.
That's where your imagination place.
And of course that's the case,
right?
Because when you encounter something and
you don't really don't know much about
it,
you imagine what it might be.
And so it takes on the structures of
your imagination.
And so in some sense what you're dealing
with as you move through history,
you expand your domain of knowledge into
the unknown is you encounter your own
front of the seat anyways,
if you want to do about that,
you could read like volume nine and
nine,
nine one and nine,
two of you once called archetypes of the
collective unconscious and the other's
called ion.
But like it'll take you a while to crack
that.
We have to beat your head against those
folks quite a bit because what,
what young is outlining in some sense,
so shocking.
It's almost impossible to grasp once you
get the picture.
All of a sudden things flipped around
because you understand what he's talking
about.
But before then,
man,
it's,
it's tough going.
It's funny because you who has been,
um,
there was a guy named Richard Nole who
wrote a biography of yoga.
He was a jealous guy.
I think he was crooked too,
because
his book was called the area in Christ
and he used like Nazi imagery on the
cover and it was his publisher that
talked him into doing that because he
thought the book would sell more.
It's like,
you don't do that well,
or if you do,
that indicates really what you're up to,
right?
Because of the,
because of what you're willing to allow
to happen to your work.
So anybody who would have thought about
that wouldn't have used Nazi imagery to
gain economic utility out of writing a
criticism of young,
because it's,
it's,
it's a crooked maneuver.
So then you have to think,
okay,
what's,
what's he up to?
Why is he doing this now?
Youngest being sold,
he accused you in,
for example,
of basically starting a cult.
And I can understand that.
But what I found so amusing about Noah's
book is that what Yoga was actually up
to was so much more,
so much more terrifying than a mere
cult.
And it was sort of like accusing a,
uh,
like a serial killer of stealing a loaf
of bread.
It's like,
yeah,
well maybe he stole a loaf of bread,
but compared to what he was actually up
to,
it's,
it's really not relevant.
So I mean,
Ewan was trying to bring the primordial
imagination back into the world and to
make people conscious of it,
just like,
whew,
that's something that really,
that's really something.
So that reading,
I read everything you wrote except the
books that were published after his
collected works.
I read some of those.
It took me a long time and it just tore
me into bed.
Like I didn't know what the hell,
which way was up.
Halfway through those books,
I mean,
niche is bad enough because Nietzsche
will set out to destroy your
presuppositions.
In fact,
I have a client right now who's being
left late,
depressed for five years because he
wasn't particularly educated and he,
you know,
he started reading nature and he had
been a Christian and he thought,
well,
I'm a Christian.
I can take on each end.
It's like,
no,
you can't.
No,
you can't like leach.
Who was so smart that it's just,
it's mind boggling.
He,
he came up with the best narcissistic
statement,
I think that's ever been written.
And this is when he was like,
cause he,
he was very sick man and he could only
great for very short periods of time.
So we try to cram everything he could
into a single sentence.
And so each sentence is like little
bomb.
One of his now.
And then he'd write something self
referential.
So one phrase of his is,
I write more in this,
I write in a sentence what other people
write in a book.
That's pretty good.
That's a good bread.
But then he talked it right away after
he said what other people can't even
write in a book.
Yeah.
Narcissism.
And then like he just punched through
that.
But it's true.
Like that's the thing.
It's true.
So it wasn't narcissism,
I mean for anyone else,
what does it mean for him?
It was just true.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So back to human
nature,
sort of hypothesize that in order for
people to overcome the psychological
consequences of the destruction of their
religious underpinnings,
they would have to transform themselves
into virtually into the thing that they
had killed.
So natures,
and this was,
believe me for nature,
this was like a revelatory solution.
He came up with this in a book called
bus fakes there too.
Stroke.
Now everybody who reads nature starts to
read.
Thus there's is there a booster because
it's got such a cool title,
you know,
but you shouldn't read that book,
at least not until you've read,
say beyond good and evil and other books
that he wrote because thus fakes there a
booster is a weird book.
It's like the old testament revelation
and it really is,
it's like it's a fantasy.
This man comes down from the mountain
and he starts to spout off like poetic
revelations and niches.
The rest of each punks are like very,
very clear and cutting thought,
where's this one is like a,
it's like a Shakespearean drama almost.
You know?
And the reason for that is because
nature was reaching beyond the grip of
his intellect to try to formulate
answers to questions that he could not,
he could not grasp because what he was
trying to figure out is,
well,
as human beings have developed
cognitively,
in some sense,
we've escaped from our culture and our
instincts and when we're embedded in our
culture and our instincts were invented
unconsciously within a religious
framework.
It's the framework of presuppositions
from which we emerged.
Like people didn't think up,
religions,
what he has is there some little weird
little,
what we call it,
conspiracy going on for 3000 years.
It's like,
no,
it's not about power.
Even though it can be twisted to be
about power,
everything can be or twist it to be
about economics.
It's about fantasy.
You know that all that you look inside
here at the cathedral,
all you see is fantasy.
It's in,
it's in brilliant lights portrayed
everywhere.
It's trying to say something to you,
well,
what's it trying to say?
Well,
it turned out when people ask themselves
that instead of just acting it out,
they hadn't got a clue.
And it said,
I had no idea what it said any more than
you guys know why you have Christmas
trees.
So how many of you have Christmas trees?
Yeah,
why?
Well,
I dunno.
I never noticed we had Christmas trees,
you know?
No,
but my point is,
my point is that in a culture you can
follow,
you follow the customs because that's
what you do.
And,
but then when you wake up a bit and just
think,
well,
you're just like the Ph Jedi and child
who is taken out of the game and forced
to look at it,
it's like,
well,
why are you playing that game and what
are the rules?
Well,
I'd never thought about it before.
as soon as people started to think about
the games they were playing,
it was often because they encountered
other people who thought apparently
thought differently,
you know?
So if you're like a Rottie Christian and
you'd go into the east and all of a
sudden you've come up with a Buddhist,
he's smart.
It's like you to have big problems,
right?
Cause you're smart and he's smart and
you don't think the same way.
At least apparently you don't think the
same way at all.
So even if you say,
well who was Buddhist?
You know,
we should just wipe them out.
It doesn't matter because their thoughts
are already there and they've been
working on them for like a couple of
thousand years and whether you like it
or not,
they're going to make you think.
And once you start thinking about your
religion,
you're in trouble.
And so that's the situation we're in
right now.
So young took this problem that needs
you to had posed seriously.
Cause young was caught up quite
dramatically in the events of,
of,
of Nazi Germany.
Now you know,
when we think about Nazi Germany,
we think of course that it was perfectly
obvious that the Nazis were the,
were the perpetrators and that,
you know,
everyone else was the victim.
And that if we were there we would have
clearly seen that and we wouldn't have
be Nazis.
And it's like that's not true.
That isn't how it worked because these
things happen slowly.
They sorta happened piece by piece.
You know,
we started seeing a similar thing
happened I think after the,
after the twin towers fell in New York,
you know,
it's like people gave up five,
10% of their civil liberties in like a
month,
you know,
and,
and it was okay.
It was like wasn't okay.
It wasn't okay.
And it just shows you how easy that sort
of thing can,
can start.
You know,
the Germans were under tremendous stress
in the 1930s their whole economy blew
out.
They had to like take,
we'll book barrels full of billions of
marks to buy a piece of bread.
The currency fell to zero.
Unemployment was staggeringly high.
They were paying off debts like mad
because of the first world war.
And there was a real threat that the
communists were going to start a
revolution.
It's like you don't have problems like
that.
So the Germans had no idea what to do,
you know?
And,
and Hitler was a canny canny person with
a brilliant,
brilliant sense of drama.
I mean,
he was a real,
he was a master of dark fire,
that guy.
And I think his,
his unconscious fantasy was,
let's see how much we could destroy
before we die in the,
in the what?
Purifying flames.
That was Hitler.
So,
and he was,
he,
he was a compelling person and the
fantasy that he added the back of his
mind,
I'll tell you how that developed at one
point,
it was a very hard thing to escape from
and that's why the Germans became Nazis.
It wasn't like this was like magic that
had emerged and it was black magic.
So young was very interested in this
because he was in the Germanic speaking
areas of the world when this happened
and he fell,
felt himself pulled very strongly by
what the Nazis were doing,
especially in the early stages of the
development of the political platform
because things did stabilize,
you know,
and then they stabilize before they went
completely out of control.
And of course looking in retrospect,
you can see the seeds of what eventually
transpired to become such a catastrophe.
But at the time it was by no means self
evident.
It's such a thing was going to occur,
especially given all the other horrible
things that were likely to occur.
So you only had a,
at a vision at one point in on the
train,
I think it was in Switzerland that
Europe had become so covered with blood,
but the blood was starting to flow over
the mountains into Switzerland because
of course Switzerland is neutral and he
said it was one of the most horrifying
nightmares of his life.
And this was in I think 1930 it was late
late 1930s anyway,
so it was a premonition of war and
he spent a lot of time
trying to understand well if you going
to become a fascist and worship the
state and you weren't going to become a
nihilist and worship nothing,
what in the world where you going to do
exactly the Orient Yourself and how
would you protect yourself against the
attractions of blind state
identification,
for example,
or the attractions of nihilism,
you know,
you might say,
well nihilism has no traction at all
because it says to you everything is
irrelevant.
Nothing you do has any importance cause
that's nihilistic basically.
Well,
what's the,
the psychoanalyst would say,
what's the secondary gain from that?
Like,
yeah,
I do say that's what you believe.
And maybe you even knocked it out.
And you also say,
well,
you've come to that conclusion through,
you know,
a rational process of deliberation at
the psychoanalyst would say it's kind of
convenient that that also alleviates you
of all responsibility,
isn't it?
And it kind of sheds a little dampness
on your plane to pristine cognition as
the driving force between,
you know,
behind your adoption of that theory.
You know,
it's like,
it's like the Patriot who claims that,
you know,
the reason that he's kicking someone in
the head is because he's patriotic.
It's like,
no,
you're patriotic so that you can kick
someone in the head and still look at
yourself in the mirror in the morning,
has nothing to do with rational
deliberation.
And so the psychoanalysts and human was
like this in particular,
you know,
they're always extremely skeptical about
people's rational claims about their
commitments to ideology.
And rightly so.
One of the things you said lawfully.
He said some things that were so
brilliant was that people didn't have
ideas.
Ideas have people.
And when you think that,
I see,
it's like,
I think this is so funny.
It's like Dawkins idea of the meme,
you know,
some of you,
how many of you read Dawkins?
He's,
you know,
yeah.
Okay.
So dawkins has this idea of mean so
funny to read,
darkens cause it's like 20% of the way
to being a union without even knowing
it.
And so he's produced this idea called
meme,
which is these I,
their ideas,
I mean is an idea that sort of has an
independent existence in a sense because
it can affect different minds are moved
from mine to mine and he kind of thinks
of it more like a fab.
While the archetypes are means except
there no fats,
they're memes that have lasted for like
20,000 years or maybe 20 million years.
We have no idea how old they are.
And young got where Dawkins was going,
like,
you know,
50 years before and 200 stories deeper.
So it's so funny to read Dawkins because
what he is searching for,
it has already been figured out by
young,
but he's so prejudiced against any kind
of religious thinking that there's no
way he'll ever find it.
So one of the things you did was he,
he's deeply,
deeply study the substructures of
thought.
So for you,
like you know,
when we talked about piaget a bit and we
said for piaget,
you kind of built your brain from your
body upward.
Brilliant idea.
It's so smart,
but you'll,
you'll has a lot of piaget in him it's,
it's more implicit.
But for young,
not only was your
sub structures of your thought,
biological and so therefore based in
your body,
but your body was also cultural and
historical and also partly because
you're,
you're an evolved creature.
So God only knows what's in there.
3.5 billion years worth of weirdness
that you can draw on or that can,
that can move you where it wants to move
you.
But I'll also,
you're being shaped by cultural dynamics
all the time.
And human beings in particular,
like we're just watching each other like
mad all the time to see what we're up
to,
what people think of us,
how we should behaving.
Are we being boring?
Are People attracted to us?
It's like we're social right to the core
and that's another way that you can
understand an archetype.
It's like part of the archetype is that
we are social to the core,
so we're interested in other people and
more if you're extroverted and less if
you're introverted,
but it doesn't matter by the standards
of say,
solitary animals.
We're so social,
it's just unbelievable.
And so that's built in.
It's built in.
What's built in is that you find that
interesting.
That's the archetype.
The archetype is whatever it is that
makes you find that interesting.
It's beyond your control.
Like if you're extroverted,
you're interested in people.
You didn't decide that it decided it for
you.
The question is,
what is it?
Well,
it's your brain,
your brain,
your limbic system.
One of the hell back means like we don't
know what that means.
You know?
Oh,
we have no idea how your brain produces
consciousness.
Like I am,
I'm dead serious.
We haven't got a clue.
And what that indicates to me,
since we've been hacking away at it for
say 400 years,
is that the way we think about
consciousness is wrong because we're not
getting anywhere.
Like we'd go a long ways with lots of
things.
We're not getting anywhere with
consciousness.
Okay.
So back to the archetypes.
So I,
cause I can tell you how these things
arise to some degree.
So you're interested in other people say
and so you're interested in them because
they're unbelievably useful resources,
right?
Because they don't think they have
resources that you want.
Plus he won even subtle things from
them.
You want their attention,
you want to play with them,
you know,
you,
there's all sorts of things that you
need and want from other people.
So the social interactions are
incredibly valuable and informative.
But the information is interesting
because part of what every single person
is constantly broadcasting every other's
person is how to behave.
So now if you meet someone and,
and let's say you find them interesting,
well I can tell you that
the more ideal they are assuming you're
not to work,
the more ideal they are,
the more you've got to be interested in
them because that actually is what
defines ideal.
Like as you become my heel,
you can say that it's also the same as
becoming high status.
As you become ideal,
then you're interesting to people.
So that's interesting because that what
that means is that you can read off
people's interest to find out when
you're deviating from the ideal and they
don't even know what the ideal is.
The ideal is that to which their
attention is an EXEC inexhaustibly drawn
and they're always telling you when you
should fall short of the ideal always.
It's being broadcast at you all the
time.
And then your imagination back there is
to try and figure out just what is this
ideal,
you know?
Because your imagination is watching you
and a phd had sense,
noticing what you do and then trying to
figure out what that is.
So you'll have fantasies about the ideal
that that often happens in a romantic
relationship,
especially at the beginning of it,
cause you know you,
you project your idealization onto the
person that you're romantically
attracted to.
That's the projection of an archetype.
So young would say the woman will
project an animus onto the man.
The animus is her conceptualization of
the ideal man is it's unconscious
because it's rooted in fantasy and the
man will be in concordance with that
projection in some areas that's,
those are the areas where she likes him
by the way.
And we'll be discordant in other areas.
And that's the areas where she
constantly did disappoints him as the
relationship develops.
So their projection is there in part to
help the person to understand who it is
that they're dealing with.
Because when you meet someone,
you have to pee,
you have to assume something about them.
It's the same as projection.
You have to assume something about the
men.
If you find that fascinating,
which is what happens if you fall in
love,
maybe it's because they smell good or
they're symmetrical or something,
you immediately assume that,
well,
those things really mattered.
You immediately assume that they embody
the ideal.
It's an oversimplification,
but oversimplification has a basis and
the basis is,
if it's interesting to me,
it must be close to the ideal.
Well,
yeah,
except the person that you're going out
with the to is warped and Benton flawed,
twisted,
and you know,
300 ways and you'll find that out soon
enough just as they will about you.
And that often just blows the
relationship into fits because the
person will say,
well,
she wasn't who I thought she was like,
who said whoever sends she was who you
thought she was.
It's like,
where did you get the misapprehension
that she was going to be who you thought
she was?
God,
why don't you know?
You know,
here's let alone your lending referred
by your sense of smell and your ability
to detect symmetry.
It's like,
yeah,
that's not very sophisticated.
So those are,
those are,
so the adamant ananymous are two primary
human archetypes and they're very
complex.
But that kind of gets at the surface the
ideal that I was describing.
So people are broadcasting information
to each other,
which is the ideal bid will be ideal and
it's like be my ideal obviously.
But let's say,
let's say if if I took a thousand ideals
and then average them or extracted out
the common ideal,
the ideal of what was common to all of
them,
that would be a savior figures.
That's what a savior figure is.
And then now,
now and then someone comes along who
acts quite a bit like that at booth
you've got yourself a religion.
So don't be thinking that these images
that people fall around like,
like you know like what blood hounds on
the trail do.
You don't have to be thinking that those
things are like conscious cognitive
constructs.
It's like conscious cognitive constructs
like Marxism.
They last like 50 years and they kill
100 million people and then that's the
end of that.
A good religious system,
man,
that'll keep the culture going for like
3000 years.
And even at the end of it,
it doesn't disappear.
We know that the story of horace and no
serious,
for example,
drove Egypt,
like Catholicism drove Europe for like
3000 years.
That's a long time.
And then it turned into Christianity.
So it sounds like it disappeared
actually.
It's sort of transmuted into Judaism and
then turned into Christianity.
So it's not like the idea is disappear.
They can disappear at all.
And believe me,
you're just as possessed by them as any
ancient Egyptian.
It's just that you're more of a
fragmented and conflict because what
your unconscious assumes and what your
conscious mind assumes aren't the same
thing.
And so you're like,
you're all at war with yourself,
not as part of what makes you attracted
to like more on etiologies.
By which I mean any of the Ology,
because they're all,
they're all false idols and false gods
and there's shallow,
they're shallow and deadly and they ruin
your life.
They destroy your soul.
So that's just a catastrophic response
and that's why it's so terrible to have
that discordance between your
instinctual being,
your deep instinctual b and your little
fragile,
you know,
halfway that conscious mind that sort of
thinks it's in control.
It's like you're not in control of
anything.
Leave me best you can do is follow
what's right.
That's the best you can do.
Wait,
I mean,
we even know this neurologically to some
degree.
Like if you look at the hypothalamus,
it's a little part of the brain we'll
talk about quite a bit.
It's sort of where the Freud Freud and
resides to the degree that it resides
anywhere.
It's this collection of nuclei that do
things like make you hungry or make you
thirsty or make you,
you know,
sexually desirous or um,
make you defensively impressive or make
you terrified of an intruder who,
who,
who threatens your dominant status.
It's this little tiny part of your
brain.
It's hardly even there at all as massive
projections coming up into the CORTEX.
And then there's little tendrils going
down to regulate it.
And so basically as long as everything
is pretty much perfect,
your conscious mind is in control.
But as soon as things deviate from the
path to any degree whatsoever,
the really smart parts of your brain
take over and then you do what they tell
you to do or you suffer the
consequences.
So you see this with people who've been
geed for example,
or sometimes people develop a condition
called Polydypsia,
which is often a consequence of
hypothalamic damage attended on a stroke
and they'll drink water until they die.
You cannot stop because they,
they're ragingly thirsty.
Like someone who is starving and like
you can say,
well you've had enough water.
It's like,
no,
that is not going to cut it.
It's not,
you're not getting anywhere with that.
And you see the same thing with people
who have like obsessive compulsive
disorders,
something like that.
When they're not in the grip of the
disorder,
they're perfectly normal.
You get those people to touch something.
They don't want to talk just like
they're not the same person.
The second they do that and whatever
they thought of themselves,
you know the themselves that was
supposed to be in control.
That bloody thing is like,
it's like a wagon with a child and it
being towed behind an elephant.
There's just,
it's got no control at all.
So you have,
one of the things that's terrifying
about yoga is that there,
there's no escaping the realization of
the nature of the forces that are behind
the puppets that we are,
you know,
in Pinocchio.
That's why Pinocchio was a puppet,
right?
Something's pulling his strings.
He's a marionette and the things that
are pulling the strings,
while they might have his best interest
in mind,
but they might not too.
And so that's what Pinocchio was about
actually.
And it's also about how not to be a
mannequin.
It turns out that you have to go to the
bottom of the ocean and find your father
in a whale and then drown.
That's how you start from being a
puppet.
It's like,
and you think,
well you don't believe that.
And I would say,
well,
yes you do.
You went and watched the movie and you
enjoyed it.
Not only that you understood it,
even though you don't have any idea what
it's about.
And also on the face of it,
it's absolutely absurd.
It's like it's not a pocket first,
it's a drawing of a puppet.
So that's weird that like,
that's two levels of weird.
And then like what the hell is been the
cricket where he comes from,
you know,
and what's,
what's his role and why is he the
conscience and why does he get like
activated by a ferry?
And why is the Pfarius starts like
you're in there,
you know,
like cletus the slack joy,
you'll pull watching the screen
captivated by it and you know,
you walk out and you don't even notice
that you're so peculiar that it,
it's just beyond belief.
You don't even notice that.
That's so peculiar.
It's like,
what the hell are you doing in that
theater watching this marionette follow
a bug route to an eight to a whale.
It's like you walk out,
oh,
that was so touching.
Really.
Like,
really?
People are really crazy and weird.
Like,
we're like rhinoceroses the report
platypuses or ostriches or penguins
were,
we're right to the core.
And when you start to,
the weirdness is so deep,
it's so ancient that even starting to
touch consciousness of that just it's
just rocks your boat.
So,
but,
but one thing or another will rock your
boat.
So sometimes it's nice to choose what,
what thing it is and prepares you for
things too.
So I'll tell you part of what an Lto
needs and Nokia,
Mary Nett,
anybody can pull the strings.
I mean,
he's got a good heart,
but what's not worth nothing?
Virtually nothing because he's naive.
You know,
you can,
it's the Fox and the,
what is it?
That stupid cat that manipulate him,
right?
And basically behind them you'll see the
devil because that devil pops out quite
quickly and Pinocchio.
And he's the thing that's behind all the
local manifestations of evil that are
trying to pope UN occhio strings and he
gets blown off the right path,
pretty badly.
Almost turns into a unconsciously brain
donkey who ends up working in the slave
minds,
which is exactly what happens.
By the way,
you know,
to,
that's what happened to devout communist
who found themselves swallowed up by
Stalins nightmare in the 1940s in the
1950s slow.
Well we were so good.
We did everything you wanted.
It's like,
yeah,
well it turned out what we wanted is for
you to die painfully.
So you know,
congratulations.
in that brilliantly laid out in an oak
hill,
which in fact was written in the 1930s
brilliantly laid out.
It's it's way,
it's way more intelligent analysis of
the 1930s than anything you'll ever find
that was written.
So Pinocchio,
you know,
he's trying to cue the proper path and
he learns that he shouldn't lie.
That's an,
that's a,
what do you call archetypal idea,
telling you why that is later.
And it turns out that in order to get
out of the horrible mess that he's put
himself in,
partly by being un UN Unsung,
a slavish adherence,
adherence to like momentary pleasure and
nihilism,
you know,
he ends up half a jackass who can't
speak properly without breaking.
So that makes him an idiot log.
And the only way that he can get out of
that is to go down to the bottom of the
ocean as deep as he could possibly go
deeper than anything is willing to go to
find his father.
What's his father?
His father is the culture that he lost
touch with.
You know,
and to the degree that you guys are
lost,
like all human beings are lost.
The reason you're lost,
it's because you've never rescued your
father from the bottom of the ocean.
You haven't gone deep enough.
You won't,
you won't even know when it was
necessary.
It's necessary.
You're a social historical cultural
creature right down to where you become
a biological creature.
And if that isn't part of you,
and if that part isn't functioning
properly,
then your,
you can just be blown off course by the
wind.
There's nothing to you.
You're not grounded in anything.
That's partly why the shoreham and when
they go down,
communicate with their ancestors,
that's what they're trying to do.
And they're trying to pull up the
cultural understructure of their,
of their societies up into consciousness
to make use of it.
And you constantly have to have a
dialogue with that because you know,
say,
say your background just for the sake of
argument has Jewish,
a lot of the lines of have,
you know,
the culture that you're embedded in was
written down by people several thousand
years ago.
It's like,
it's not easy to figure out what the
hell those people were talking about or
why it's relevant to you.
So there has to be a dialogue
continually going on between the present
and the past so that you can bring the
wisdom forward without losing what's in
it.
Because if you lose what's in it,
it's like you're just nowhere.
You know,
I see this all the time and you might in
my practice,
you know,
often that happens to people who get
divorced or who are living together and
not married,
which you think,
well,
you're free.
It's like you don't want her to be that
free.
You know,
you want to argue with your partner
about every single thing for the rest of
your life.
Well,
that's what you have to do.
If you don't let your culture guide you,
it's like there's no rules.
Go ahead.
Make up all the rules.
See how easy that is,
Christ,
that'll kill the average person in 10
years.
It's just such a weight and you only
have one life.
You know?
You might as well let some tradition
guide you so you have some pieces some
of the time,
or you'll end up divorced and with
children's,
ew,
ew.
That's cancer for lots of people.
They get divorced,
they have children,
they get locked into a custody battle
and they're done.
That's the end of the ride.
They're ruined by it.
So you step outside of the guidelines of
your culture at your own peril and
modern people because they're so
coddled.
They,
oh yeah,
well we can handle it.
It's like,
sure you can.
You wait until you get there.
You'll find out that you can't handle it
and it'll be too late.
What will has,
what will have happened is that you know
the way all that you were supposed to go
confront and rescue your father from has
risen out of the water and taking you
down and you're done.
That's chaos.
So these are serious issues.
Like Yo,
I would say it was the most serious
thinker of the 20th century.
I think he was.
So,
he was so serious that the pseudo
serious people who read them just bounce
off them.
They don't even know what the hell he's
up to.
So in young was one of those thinkers
who was addressing questions that most
people don't know exist,
like at the bottom of reality,
and who was also answering them.
So he's a twofold blow to the intellect.
First he tells you that you're so
stupid,
you don't even know what's wrong.
You can't even ask the right questions.
And then he answers them.
It's like,
Whoa,
boy.
Yeah,
that'll,
uh,
doing your intellectual pretentions.
So,
and the contrast between darkens I think
in young is exactly the right contrast.
It's the contrast between the
intelligent modern Dawkins in the sort
of historically centered.
Why is math?
And it's sort of painful for me to watch
because I've kind of watched golf.
You know,
he's,
he's not a happy man and he's got a
tremendous resentment against the
church.
I'm sure it's something terrible.
Must have happened to him when he was a
child,
but
okay.
Anyways,
let me show you some of this stuff
because it's such fun.
It's such fuck,
did it sound fun?
Not really.
Okay,
so I'm going to show you the opening in
the lion king.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Good,
good,
good idea.
Good idea.
Thanks.
Like why not use a media player?
That works.
Okay.
Okay,
so what I'm going to play for you is the
opening scene,
the opening scene.
It's very nicely designed.
So the music I find a little bit
manipulative.
It's a little poppy and,
and it's manipulated.
Like it's an interesting example of how
art can go wrong because it's sort of
art design for a purpose and art cannot
be designed for a purpose.
The purpose of art is art purpose,
not your purpose.
And so if you're trying to bend the arc
to your purpose,
it's like you're,
you're like you're painting a picture of
a stick man on a stained glass window.
Like you just don't have,
you just haven't got the right
orientation.
Art is an exploratory process and it's
supposed to take you beyond what you
know.
If you take art and try to force it into
your precut pre conceptions,
then you're,
you're a propagandist and an Nydia log
and it's like you're,
you're bending the greater to the lesser
so in that makes it feel cheap and,
and,
and
it doesn't fit well.
And like the Latin kings a pretty good
movie.
And I mean from a,
from a psychological perspective,
it devolves into propaganda from time to
time.
That happens isn't salts,
but you know,
it's,
it's still a work.
It's a work of genius,
which is why you will know it.
This is where you get your religion.
Okay.
So that's an archetypal image they open
with it,
right?
So it's the dawn of consciousness,
so it's the new day,
but it's also the dawn of consciousness,
dawn of consciousness because you're a
visual creature and it's also the dawn
of consciousness because you wake up in
the morning,
so it's like sun rise,
light dawn of consciousness,
and then the music is a celebration of
that and you can feel it in grips you
right away.
I mean that,
that part of the music is really,
really nice.
I think that's the gospel singers from
South Africa.
I think it is the guys that played with
Paul Simon.
I think so.
They're great.
Okay.
So what are all the animals doing all of
a sudden
and you're waking up and they're paying
attention to a call,
right?
And call his musical.
So then the question is,
well,
what's music?
Well,
music is a representation of like the
dynamic patterns of things.
And so you get all of this complex
information that's going on right off
the bat.
Consciousness dawns.
And now there's a call and everything
that San Diego is to pay attention to
the call.
That's pretty good for like five seconds
of film.
Okay.
So now there's,
you feel makers hit you with a whole
succession of very beautiful images and
you know,
they do that with a very beautiful music
that's underneath.
And that's to put you like in a state of
harmony with,
well normally with nature,
but with your own conceptions of the
beetroot and your sense of aesthetics.
It works quite nicely.
Put pops into a dream very quickly.
Yeah.
On
staffing.
See
then can have a
pc
small.
Okay.
So there's a lot going on there.
So the lyrics are quite interesting
because the lyrics are making
representation to the,
to that state of being that I talked to
you about that William James had
experienced stay with is nitrous oxide
visions.
But then also the piaget and the
constructivist sort of think about as
the ground of being.
So you know the,
the,
the lyricist made the case that what
surrounds you is informative to a degree
that you will never be able to
comprehend it.
And the implication under that is that
you know,
that at least one of the ways of
construing the ground of experiential
being is as an information rich matrix
and the music is pushing you in that
direction too.
Because the music is,
the music is a representation of what
that information rich matrix is like
because if it's patterned and complex
but understandable,
but it,
and it also evokes emotion.
So that's reality.
And there's a lot of paradise imagery in
here.
Two ways because it's sort of like all
these animals are,
they're all doing the same thing in
them,
sort of existing in harmony,
like elephants covered with birds.
And so in a way it's a childish view of
the world because you know those
elephants are covered with the text and
you know,
the lions are half starved because it's
been a drought.
You know,
it's,
it's not so good out there on the
African plains because it's not all,
you know,
that'll teach me,
okay,
so,
but,
but they're getting you in the mood.
Now the,
the,
the lyricist also made reference to the
fact that there's this,
there's a,
there's a paradise.
There is an element of genesis in that
systems because she talks about our
arrival on the earth,
so to speak,
and then are the dawning of
consciousness,
which is this step into the sun.
And so that's an archetype of multim
were placed on earth while here we are
after all.
And poof,
we woke up.
And that,
the reason that's an archetypal ideas,
cause that's what happens to everybody.
Great.
Poof,
you're placed on the earth bag.
One day you wake up.
It's like the internal experience of
human beings and there's something
that's deeply real about it.
Okay,
that was cool.
So we're going to force them to watch
that again.
So that's a revelation,
right?
And so that's a very sneaky bit at the
camera work.
So you know,
first of all,
your,
your vision is obscured,
but then it's,
it's directed by the motion to this like
place.
What's that?
Well,
that's a good question.
It's what,
and just what exactly is in pride Bra.
[inaudible]
that's right.
The Rock is where the king is.
That's the top of the pyramid.
And we remember those,
remember those trees I showed you from
the showman?
It's so cool.
I just figured this out the other day.
Inside that tree there was a mountain
and the mountain was surrounded by a
snake.
You remember that?
There's a circle with the sneaker on it.
That's exactly the structure of this
lion king set up.
You remember that?
So you've got the mountain in the middle
there.
What's on the outside?
Hyenas.
That's right.
The chaos is out there where the light
won't touch.
Right?
It's a perfect representation of the
Scandinavian world tree.
So cool.
So okay,
now obviously you and other animals are
supposed to lift up your eyes,
which is what the film maker made you
do.
And focus on this thing.
It's a raw,
what does the Rock,
what does a rock stand for?
Hmm.
Yes,
exactly.
Why balance structure?
Why?
Why is it rock a good metaphor for that?
That's great rocks there.
They're strong.
Even in an earthquake,
if you're lucky,
they won't liquefy.
So you can,
you want to stand on a rock,
right?
The question is what kind of rock do you
want to stand on?
And that's exactly,
is it a physical rock that's one way of
looking at it or is there a metaphysical
rock that's even a better rock?
Well,
that's partly what this is film
investigates,
but at the moment there was a rock and
it's been there forever and the king has
been there forever and the king is the
thing.
You have to talk with the dominance
hierarchy,
which is why you lift up your eyes to
it.
And the king here is a lion.
Why does that make sense?
Lions aren't kings after all,
but maybe sense why
they're up there at the top of the food
chain.
Okay.
So that's a good one.
Any other possible reasons?
Yes.
Yeah,
that's good.
definitely.
And the,
and the animators capitalized on that
all the time and they're kind of noble
looking,
you know,
cause they're muscular and,
and,
and plus they could eat you.
Right.
So that sort of indicates that there are
certain circumstances under which you
are at the bottom of the hierarchy and
the lion is it in fact at the tall.
So cause a lion is also an on spiring
beast.
Like,
you know,
the shepherds in the old testament
around that time,
you know,
a shepherd,
you think,
well shepherd,
he's dressed this little frilly hat and
you know,
he's,
he's not much of a powerhouse at all,
but those guys used to fight off lions.
It's like,
that's,
you gotta be really tough to fight off a
lion with a steak,
you know?
So,
yeah.
So anyways,
okay,
so there's the rock and the sun is
shining on it.
And what are the animals doing
gathering around the rock.
Now we accept that as a narrative
possibility,
right?
You don't sit in their thinking and the
theater,
what the hell are those animals doing?
Gathering around the Rock and the fact
that you're not sitting there thinking
that is an indication that you're
following the archetypical trail of the
story.
It makes sense to you that a diverse
bunch of drawings of animals would,
you know,
come together around a rock.
That makes sense.
Why?
Well,
it had something to do with our,
our dawn higher proclivity and the fact
that we can recognize a,
an authority and an authority structure
and we know how to interact with them.
And so these aren't animals after all,
they're here.
There are people,
while they're not cause their drawings,
but they're certainly not animals.
They're not acting like him.
So,
or they're acting like half human,
half animals.
Great.
Right
now.
Who's that little guy?
Okay.
What?
What's he good for?
Information.
Yes.
Why?
Why is he did frequent aging and so,
so what,
why is that relevant?
You can get up there way the hell up
there with the king.
Can't even see and he can see
everything.
It's horses.
Argh.
That's exactly right.
That's the,
that's the Egyptian I that says pay
attention.
And so the birdies,
the divert his attention fundamentally.
So,
and the king by the same for the bird,
he's a little ratty.
Burton,
he's kind of funny.
I think he's,
he's not English comedian so he's a bit
of a comical character but the king,
the king will listen to him.
And so that shows that this king is
properly humble king because it's just a
stupid bird and you could like fight it
and half in one bite,
which is kind of what scar trump
threatens to do cause scarred is want to
pay attention cause then he'd figured
out who he was.
So but the king he'll pay attention to
even,
you know this is also why in fairy tales
it's often the youngest son,
the oldest son is usually the one who
everyone likes and admires.
You know,
he's like the football,
you'd like to football quarterback,
you know,
of the fairytale.
And the younger son is like,
well he's kind of little weaselly
useless guide and the older son always
fails.
And then usually the second son fails
to,
and it's usually because they're
arrogant.
And then the third son,
he's so clueless,
he doesn't know what to do,
but they kicked them out because they
just assume get rid of him and,
and you know,
why not let them go and you don't want
them around anyways.
And so he wanted out in the bush and you
know,
he comes across out of nome or something
that,
you know,
it's like you just ignore it.
The other brothers did,
but he doesn't know what the hell he's
doing.
So the talks to many thanks while our
plans,
we'll talk to this known,
you know,
then the gnome tells them what to do
and,
and then then the youngest son wins.
And that's an archetypal story too.
It's like if you don't know what you're
doing,
don't be so sure that you know who to
ignore.
Now,
that's our very,
very useful piece of advice.
But then you might ask yourself,
how do you know when you don't know what
you're doing?
So do you have any thoughts on that?
How is it that you would know if you
didn't know what you were doing?
Yes,
but there's one that's very good,
that's very good.
But there's one more thing that goes
along with that all and I'll just add
it.
Cause it's lets you know a bit of a trek
and substance and it's bothering you,
right?
So there's,
there's failure plus suffering.
Now one of the inferences that you can
draw from failure plus suffering is that
nature is your enemy and you're a victim
of the great father.
He's like very standard presupposition,
especially of young people because of
course you're failing here young.
It's like what the hell?
You know,
you know when you go to a whole bunch of
things to learn yet before you can be
successful.
But you know,
but it's an art that's an architectural
situation in large part.
Okay,
so
great,
great.
So now we see the cake.
So what do we notice about the cake?
It's kind of a tough looking guy.
He's not one of these defeated lobster
types of lion kings.
He's like an upstanding of,
okay,
you saw he was also in the sun,
right?
So if the sun shines on the king,
and that's because the king is awake and
the sun also illuminates it.
You may not know this,
but you have,
you've seen coins,
of course silver coin,
that's the mood.
The head of the Queen was the head of
the queen on the mood and gold coins
with the sun.
And so we're hanging clothes.
And the idea is that the thing that's at
the top,
it's like the sun.
And why is it like the sun?
Because the sun is consciousness.
And why is this unconsciousness?
Because you're awake during the day.
Now there's a bunch of other reasons as
well.
The Sun is also the thing that defeats
darkness and that's what the king should
be.
And that's right in their coins.
And they're simple.
They're symbols of value.
Okay,
so they're all on the wind is blowing on
it,
but just not bothering you by the way.
But that's a,
that's a divine wind.
That's PNEUMA.
PNEUMA that's spirit because spirit is
often win as an inspiration and
respiration.
That's all spirit.
So spirit came here,
comes to the bird.
It's not lunch.
It's his friend.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Now who in the world is that?
That's Carl Young.
Who's that?
The Virgin Mary and Christ.
That's the virgin and the sun.
It's a way older idea.
Then the Christian idea.
It's been around forever.
Why?
Because any culture that doesn't worship
the mother and child dies obviously.
So it's an archetypal image of value.
Clearly.
Obviously you don't have to think about
that much.
So,
oh,
oh yeah.
I love that.
There's,
there's two things always happen when I
showed this always,
because it evokes archetypal emotions.
So you were all going nick invoice from
that cute noises,
right?
What kind of noises are those
babies?
Like that noise.
That's why you're making that noise.
It's like the baby like that though.
I still smile at you and then you'll
take that the navy likes you even though
it's just a survival mechanism.
It
is,
but the baby.
So what?
Why is that cute?
First of all,
it's not real.
You might notice that.
Yeah.
Why is that cute?
What means of cute?
They guys.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
that's,
that's part of it.
Aliens have big eyes too though.
What else?
It's kindly.
Yeah.
So it's a Mammalian,
that's how small the lizard,
you know,
so that's helpful.
It's got first so you can pet it sort of
invites be petted and it moves like
this.
It was like,
that's so cute.
You know,
that little polar bear.
I did watch a little bit of that,
like,
that's like pathologically acute,
that thing.
And it's,
you know,
part of it is,
it's sort of wobbling around and it's
like the poor thing.
It's trying to walk.
It's having a rough time and everybody
thinks,
oh,
that's so cute.
That was happening to you.
You wouldn't think it was cute.
But you know,
animals,
first range of mammalian species,
no cute.
You know,
and they tend to respond to like big
guide,
symmetrical small nose,
flat faced,
uh,
helpless movement cuddly and not eat it.
Right.
It's,
it's,
so,
it's an inhibitory,
it's a set of inhibitory perceptual
mechanisms in large part.
But since we're also mammals,
you better think that thing is cute
because you're going to be taken care of
it for a long time.
So you know there has to be a deep,
deep,
deep biological connection.
It's forged almost immediately.
And of course that's mediated in women
in particular by Oxytocin,
which is released in tremendous
quantities after birth and during
breastfeeding.
So,
and it's necessary,
you know,
it turns on new circuits and there are
circuits you need cause like one day
you're not a mother and then the next
day you are,
that's not,
you are not the same creature at that
point and you don't want to even be the
same creature.
You're pretty happy about the whole
issue.
Hopefully.
So that's very interesting image j
because first of all he was playing with
the little lion king with those balls
and they're,
so there's sort of globe thing that's
attracting them.
So it was like representations of the
sun and you might think,
well you're just reading that into it.
But then of course this happens.
It's like this is,
this is like he's breaking open the sun
to release the essence of the sun onto
the little lion king.
And he is because the sun represents
gold.
Gold is pure gold,
won't mix with any other metals.
So that's partly why it's a symbol of
value.
It's a noble metal.
The Sun is made out of gold so to speak,
except it's like medical from a symbolic
perspective because it's like the gold
of higher consciousness and it feed
dumped on the middle lion king because
for the tribe sake and then maybe even
for the sake of the whole ecosystem
around the tribe,
that king better be awake.
So that's what this Carl Young baboons
here is trying to get.
Get going.
Okay,
so now you notice two things.
Lovely.
This is lovely.
Very well put together seeing third
bottle.
So the animal is started to lift up your
head so you can get the sense of
heightened interest in the music is
starting to rise a little bit in speed
up in camp a better,
you know what?
Something's going to happen here at
pinnacle of the,
of the,
of the rock there.
Brilliant.
This little thing was now represents
what will become the guiding
consciousness of the land is revealed
and the automatic response of all the
animals,
it's first to file.
So they're in awe as they should be.
And then to celebrate and then that's,
you know,
well that's pretty good.
It's pretty impressive.
But then God himself gets in the act
because just at the opportune time,
the sun breaks and shines on the little
lion at the same time.
They moved the music up like they
changed the key of the music.
And so if it causes an up swelling of
emotion and that's,
y'all would call that if,
if,
and when that happened,
that's what he would call a synchronous
event.
So that's a demonstration of a
synchronous event.
It's where they're very rare.
These things there from a union
perspective,
they're there.
They occur in very emotionally intense
situations where they context,
the external context of the occurrence
seems to match the meaning of the
occurrence.
So anyways,
whether or not you believe such things
are possible,
that is exactly what this little film
clip is trying to demonstrate.
Yup.
Pretty decent or right.
So you go up the animals,
you've got the stone hierarchy,
that's a pyramid.
You've got the thing that's at the top
of it,
just like the little pyramid on the back
of the American dollar bill with the eye
on talk.
Exactly the same.
And part of the idea is that the thing
that's at the very top of the pyramid
isn't part of the fear of it.
So it's not stolen.
A little lion king,
he isn't stone.
He's the thing that produces stone as he
moves through time,
right?
Because he's the culture producing
force.
And so this is setup to demonstrate
visually that at the center of being is
culture at the top of culture is the
culture producing process or force.
And that's the illuminated savior.
And that's what all the animals worship
instinctively.
It's like,
yes,
that's right.
That's how it goes.
We'll see you on
Tuesday.
Okay.